Hi!
I'm Ana.
Welcome to 'What to Say!'
Do you know what to say when you
want to keep a conversation going?
Listen out for useful language for
keeping a conversation going.
Then, we'll practise saying the
new phrases –
after this.
Hi, Bob!
Oh, morning, Noelia.
So, what's new?
New, hmm,
let me think.
Hmm … Nothing much.
Oh, hang on.
My dog Bertie had his 14th birthday
on Monday!
Oh, he's getting old then?
I guess so …
but not as old as his owner.
Haha …
er, anyway …
How about you, Noelia?
How's it going?
Great, actually.
Yeah … all good.
By the way,
I wanted to ask you, where in
Spain are you from?
I'm from Santander.
Oh, lovely.
Wonderful to grow up near the sea.
Yeah, it was perfect.
Ah, I miss the sea.
I know what you mean.
I used to live in Spain
and I absolutely loved it.
Really?
I didn't know that, Bob!
Yeah, I had a little bar on
the Costa Brava.
Wow! So do you speak Spanish then?
Oh, not much.
Ah, those were the days!
Excuse me.
Perdona, Noelia. Tengo que irme. Me necesitan en el segundo piso. ¡Hasta pronto!
Wow!
Hello again!
Wow! Bob is full of surprises.
So, did you notice the useful phrases
used for keeping a conversation going?
Listen to me and then repeat.
So, what's new?
Let me think ...
Nothing much.
Anyway …
How about you, Noelia?
How's it going?
By the way, I wanted to ask you ...
I know what you mean.
Really? I didn't know that!
Try and use some of these phrases the next time you want to keep a conversation going in English.
Bye for now!